SPEAKER: Hi.
Welcome to this
series on geocasts,
where you can walk your
way through what you
can do with Google Maps APIs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In part one, we saw how you
could delegate your mapping
work to the Google Maps app.
In part two, we saw how
you could go further
by incorporating Google
Maps functionality
right in your app.
In this video, we'll
go a bit deeper
and we'll talk about
integrating maps more deeply
and customizing the maps
experience for the user.
First, let's take a
look at the bus tracker
app that was written
for Google I/O. Now
here's a screenshot of it.
Consider the map here
and how it's concisely
styled to the rest of the app.
In this example, we're doing
it using the JS Maps API V3,
but custom styling is also
available on Android and iOS.
Now, often you'll want
to style your experience
to match whatever else
is on your app or site.
And you need to build
everything around that.
So the map is only
a part of your site.
So here's an example
of the styling
that we used in order
to have a map fade
into the background of this app.
It allows the user to focus
on the important information,
like the nearby bus stops.
Next up, let's
look at the camera
and how you can use
it on Android and iOS
to really bring
your maps to life.
For example, check out
downtown Los Angeles here.
By tweaking the
camera settings, I'm
making the experience
feel more real.
3D buildings pop up.
And I'm able to see this
place the same way I would
if I was there.
It's quite a bit
better than just
looking at these top down maps.
Now you can achieve this sort
of effect with very little code.
And here's how we
did it on Android.
We've been changing the
bearing, tilt, and zoom values
to give us this perspective.
But to make that camera
move around more slowly,
we've been using the
animate camera method.
And what it does is it looks
at your source and destination
and then interpolates
a path there
so that the camera smoothly
animates to that position.
So we've seen it on Android.
Let's look at what
it looks like on iOS.
It's quite similar, right?
We've seen the 3D
buildings and those maps
are just coming alive.
The code is also quite similar.
We have a camera.
And then we set some
parameters on it.
We're creating a
GMS camera position,
and then providing those
appropriate values.
Now just something to note--
what we called tilt on Android
we're calling view angle
or viewing angle on iOS.
Now let's look at a
different scenario--
one that involves markers.
Here we have a map of
Italian restaurants in Rome.
Now, Italian restaurants
in Rome means
that you have a lot of markers.
So it's not very easy to
see all of these markers
as you're looking at the map.
So that's where marker
clustering helps us.
And it's available in the maps
utils open source libraries.
And what we can do is take
these markers and group them
into clusters.
And it provides a
better user experience,
and also provides
better performance.
So implementing it
actually ends up often
with less code than if you were
managing the markers yourself.
So let's have a look
at the code and you'll
see that it's a four
step process on Android.
What we're doing is we're
adding the utils library
to your gradle configuration.
Then we need to go and
implement a cluster item
interface on our data classes.
In our example, this
would be the object that
stores restaurant information.
What we'll then do is
instantiate a ClusterManager,
and then register the
camera and marker click
listeners to that manager.
Then all we have to do is
go and add our data items
to the ClusterManager.
Now these are those
same data items
we talked about that hold
the restaurant information,
and have implemented that
cluster item interface.
That's it.
You can then remove your
marker management code,
since this library
will handle it for you.
Now in this example, we've
looked at Android code,
but we also have a utils
library on iOS that
includes marker clustering.
And you can go
grab it right here.
So we've looked at
marker clustering,
but I want to show you another
great visualization-- heat
maps.
So let's look at that heat map
of Rome with those restaurants.
And you can immediately
see that those restaurants,
those locations of restaurants,
are now grouped by colors.
You can see where
the busy areas, where
are the hot spots,
quite literally,
and interesting areas
for us to visit.
So as I zoom in and out, I
get a really nice experience.
In terms of the code, it's very
similar to what we just saw.
And it's pretty simple.
This time we have a
three step process.
We add our utils library
to the gradle config.
We then go and instantiate
a HeatMapTileProvider
and pass in those data items.
And then we just go ahead
and create the tile overlay.
That's it.
So now you've seen
how you can delegate
your work to Google Maps.
You've seen how you can
incorporate Google Maps
functionality into your app.
And in this episode,
you've seen technologies
for integrating maps and
maps data in your apps.
In the next video,
we're going to go
to the deepest point--
taking raw data from Google
and using it in your apps.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]